[Applause]
thank you for having me i'm so excited
that you would grace us with your
presence oh my god i mean it i'm like
hanging on your words talk about
why they're calling you the big sister
of tick tock i like to give out advice i
think it's all about sharing information
and if i have a tip that can save a girl
a couple weeks of agony over thinking
about a boy she barely even dated then
that's a win for me
see that's a win for everybody
exactly it's about sharing the
information
you know whatever you know i don't know
everything lord knows i don't know
everything but i've picked up a thing or
two over over my time is it experience
that has given you this wisdom or is it
just this innate ability to know i think
it's experience and you know what i
actually love asking for advice a lot
too so i think it's kind of a cyclical
thing like i'll ask for advice i'll
listen i'll pass it on it's it's kind of
a back and forth type of thing i totally
agree and you're about to get your own
call-in show which i am so excited about
[Applause]
so excited it's me tinks and it's on
siriusxm
i mean this is so good how are you
approaching it what are you excited
about i'm just so excited for this
opportunity to take my relationship with
my followers to the next level because i
love making tick tocks i love answering
dms but there's something so intimate
about being in in someone's ear and also
hearing a voice you know the power of
just talking back and forth is so
powerful so i'm just i'm really excited
for this next step and to for to grow
with my followers they've been there
with me since the beginning
thank you thank you but
i also just think how do tinks come up
it's so pithy and like cute and
optimistic it's a you know it's a funny
story it's actually a nickname i've had
for 20 years it's based on a movie
character named tinker parker from this
little known movie called strike about
an all-girls school anyway long story
short there was this cool girl in the
movie and i thought i want to be
confident like her
so i started i went to my friends i said
you guys you got to call me tinker from
now on because i'm like her it was my
sasha fierce moment i had an alter ego
and you know what fake it till you make
it works because slowly over time i just
started to become tinker parker this
confident girl and i've been called
tanks ever since i love it and if
beyonce needs an alter ego we all know
there you go for sure
um
i love the box theory is about um i mean
you saw the videos so you know what it's
about um but that really resonated with
people i feel like you got a lot of
response to that like it really did go
extremely viral and people felt
passionate about that you were right
yeah and that people do get put in boxes
and can't get out of them yeah i think
you know my hope is that it saves people
time you know because i get so many
messages from girls saying i'm trying to
get this guy to date me what can i do
you know if i talk about how much i love
golden retrievers if if i don't hook up
with him like what will make him want to
date me and i'm like why are you trying
to get someone to date you who doesn't
want to date you you're in the hookup
box leave it you're good
nothing you do
can make someone want to date you nor
should it because someone should want to
you know there's a person out there for
everybody who there's no games it's just
easy and that's what you're looking for
[Applause]
the simplest advice but it's so true
just be you and when the right person
fits it fits yeah don't try to
manipulate your way into a relationship
because those never pan out and trust me
i have done the legwork
[Music]